authorities in Idaho are trying to track
down exactly how Brian coburger may have
known any of the four alleged victims
all University of Idaho students Kaylee
Gonzalez Madison Mogan zonner kernodle
and Ethan shape and all died November
13th in a home near campus they were
viciously stabbed to death police
identified co-burger and announced his
arrest but haven't said anything about
his connection to the four students
coburger was part of a doctoral program
at Washington State University which is
just about 20 minutes away from Moscow
Idaho but when asked about co-burger a
friend of Kaylee Madison said she had
never seen him or heard of him in fact
the bar where Kaylee and Madison were
seen on the night of the murders the
corner Club posted on Twitter that
coburger had never been in the bar
before and was not there on that fateful
night right now I want to bring back in
Brian to talk a little bit more about
the clues of law enforcement so Brian we
know the police searched coburger's
apartment they searched the parents home
at this point at this point what does it
tell us yeah Jesse with the affidavit
sealed and a gag order I believe in
place we could take an educated guess as
to what the police are looking for
search once were his person his home in
Pennsylvania and his car does tell us a
little bit about this investigation
first the search of us person they
probably wanted to get his DNA they may
already have it or what they suspect to
be his DNA but they want a clean chain
of custody of his DNA to the test
facility imagine the defense argues the
DNA collected could have been his father
and not him during their cross-country
trip they don't want that his home in a
car that white Elantra I don't think
they will find the murder weapon I would
guess he threw it away during the trip
police are more like like more likely
looking for any genetic material from
the victims in the cars or on his
clothes yeah even his clothes sure he is
a masters in criminology and was a PhD
student but there is school and then
there's real life he may not be as smart
as he'd think and left clues for the
police to connect him to these murders
there may not be the proverbial Smoking
Gun in this case but a victim's DNA in
his car or on his clothes that he
brought home with him that may just be
as good as the murder weapon at trial
you see what uh Brian said Terry the
father so we know that coburger's father
was in the car with him when he was
stopped on the road could he be
connected to the crime in any way you
know what's interesting I'm wondering
whether or not these two were released
early on and then they just looped back
around and got them so I think the
father could very well be involved and
here's why why was he in that car
driving back from Washington State and
going to Pennsylvania he's with his son
I'm sure they had conversations in that
car one of the things I think we have to
be really clear on is that DNA what if
the DNA was partly the father and not
the son will they be arguing that in
court who knows but the other issue is
was the father trying to Aid and abet
his son somehow in the crime or was he
an accessory after the fact somehow
driving him away from the scene of the
crime we don't know these answers and
I'm hoping that we get more information
when we actually see the indictment and
certainly when the evidence comes in but
I would would not completely rule out
the father at this point just because
he's in that car trying to get away from
the scene of the crime you know what I
can't get over is the fact that if
coburger did this what was going through
his mind when he stopped by police that
was like a deer in the headlights
looking at the police he maybe thought
that he was getting caught again
assuming he